en théorie t bonds mais sur le terrain
c'est pas bon ascom temps en théorie est
un bon père n'en pratiquer des forums je
sais combien ça coûte à la société
suicide franchement c'est quoi ton
problème vous inscrire une sorte de
thérapie c'est non négociable
vous allez dans thérapie non avant tout
et refuse c'est l'expérience d'une vie
vous allez en baver c'est sûr mais vous
allez aussi vibré comme jamais pour vous
rapprocher
nous allons provoquer un puissant
mouvement tectonique vous allez choisir
une figurine qui représente votre père
quant à lui bon j'ai trouvé ça je trouve
que ça leur présente très bien entre
présenter papa j'ai choisi un tas de
merde c'est pas obligé d'utiliser des
mots c'est moins beau cri primal
on s'est pas tu cries où c'est à dire
trop c'est pas un moment de devenir
sensible est fondamental de se toucher
qu'est ce que c'est
les glisser c'était la caso ça fait 28
ans que tu as un têtard dans lequel son
savoir de faire adp sont envolés mais
voilà c'est un jeu
on n'avait pas envie de vous aimer très
en vue ils ont 873 amis sur facebook
mais quand ils doivent déménager a plus
personne déguisée qui s'appelle devrait
peut-être profité de l'occasion pour
presser de se rapprocher le progrès tu
vois non je pense pas